text University of Michigan scenes of
University of Michigan campus students
walking between buildings A young man
enters the College of Pharmacy building
Corey Lester PHD p-h-a-r-md assistant
professor of clinical Pharmacy my
proposal to the National Library of
Medicine was to develop and design
artificial intelligence specifically a
computer vision model which could look
at a picture of pills inside of
medication bottle and accurately
identify the contents of that bottle
Lester sits with another man pointing to
a computer screen showing pill data and
photos of pills in a pill bottle we are
testing how that model can be used in
collaboration with the human so that
errors don't happen in the pharmacy
close up of a person's hand using pill
counting Trends how do you teach a
machine
if you want to a machine to
differentiate between an anomaly in
medical dispensing or not what do you do
is you give the machine images of
anomalies you give the machine images of
good medications and you tell them this
is good this is bad Riot alcantar PhD
assistant professor industrial
operations engineering photos of pills
and pill bottles text how to teach
machines images of pills and pill
bottles differentiated by color tints
and labeled as bad or good white text
bad appears over red tinted pills white
text good appears over Green Tinted
bills text algorithm makes link text can
predict medication when the algorithm
can make this link then if you give the
algorithm a new image the algorithm can
predict this image belongs to which
class is it the good group or compatible
so fundamentally it's a matching
decision done in a fancy mathematical
way so the way we see this being
implemented is once we have that picture
of pills in the bottle we can use this
model to predict what medication it is
in that image and cross-reference it
with the expected or intended medication
that was supposed to be filled in this
way we can support pharmacists in their
double check verification of the patient
getting the right pill in the right
bottle the results were surprisingly
positive and we found that our algorithm
can predict with an accuracy above 99.5
text algorithm predicts over 99.5
percent accurate appears next to women
handling medication and looking at a
computer screen but what one thing that
we are afraid of even though 0.5 percent
of Errors can be critical I would hope
is that in those cases where the
algorithm is wrong the algorithm can
tell us that it is not confident in its
results then at least the human can
double check G Jesse Yang PhD associate
professor industrial operations
engineering our next step is to conduct
the experiment with Pharmacists and
through soon we are going to track how
their trust change over time on a trial
to trial basis so through the experiment
we can collect participants responses
their physiological signals and we want
to use eye tracking and by analyzing
their responses and signals we can track
how their trust changes over time how
their behaviors their performance
changes over time the ultimate goal of
this project is to develop safer systems
that can be used to save lives and
prevent medication errors from causing
harm to patients it means tons to me as
an engineer I believe our ultimate
mission is to propose solutions that can
be used to enhance people's life being
part of the projects doing just that the
National Library of medicine's financial
support of this project has really been
invaluable so really they've been
instrumental in making all of this
research possible without it we would
not have had the capability to collect
all this data to do all this analysis
and generate the promising results we
have right now the gray and blue nlm
logo Fade up over a white background
with blue text serving scientists and
Society